الشعور في الأيام القليلة الماضية أنك أشعلت النار أيضًا
إنها أكثر تحفظًا من الجو ومن الأرض
وأكثر محدودية ليس فقط بسبب نشر القوات
ربما بسبب حساب عدد الأسلحة التي أملكها
سأخبرك بشيء آخر في العالم لا يوجد وفرة من الأسلحة
أحد الأشياء التي واجهناها في هذه الحرب هو هذا
أنه لا يوجد مادة تي ان تي متوفرة في العالم ولا يوجد مادة تي ان تي ونحن كذلك
نحن بحاجة إلى مادة تي إن تي لتفجير الأنفاق، واتضح أنه لا يوجد أي منها
لذا ابدأ في إنهاء المناجم وابدأ في جمع كل شيء
نوع من الأشياء القديمة التي يمكن استخدامها
من أجل تفجير الأنفاق، قضت الحرب الدائرة
أوكرانيا تستهلك الكثير من الأسلحة والمتفجرات
ولا توجد وفرة مثل ظهور مادة تي إن تي الكبيرة
في العالم هم صينيون، نعم، لذا فالأمر ليس بهذه البساطة
الشراء منهم فيبدو أن التصرف هكذا
الذي يبدأ بالتجديف حتى النهاية لنهاية مسيرة الشجرة
والانتقال إلى المرحلة C على أمل أن يلتقيا في مكان ما
لقد ربحت الرهائن بطريقة ستكون هي الأفضل من حيث الجيش
مثالية ل